well
look washington fans we know it's a big
week winning in for the postseason we
hate to depress you
but this graphic gives you reason to not
be thrilled about the current state of
the franchise not that you need a
reminder but
first round quarterbacks in the super
bowl era at least in the last 26 years
not good
starting with heath schuler continuing
with patrick ragdoll ramsey
because it wasn't his fault he got
thrown around like the proverbial
ragdoll
during his career jason campbell was
i never felt they believed in jason
campbell the way they should i think he
could have been better if they really
truly had embraced him i don't know what
the issue was there
although it probably was disagree what
what a shock
some sort of disagreement in the upper
reaches of the organization and the
coaching staff over whether or not they
should embrace the guy but uh
then the rg3 debacle with the shanahan's
they didn't want him the owner did and
then dwayne haskins jr
all indications are the owner wanted him
nobody else did
and now uh dwayne haskins is gone
released on monday
abruptly the washington football team
choosing to rip the band-aid off and
admit the mistake and move on instead of
compounding it even though they could
have held him and maybe traded him in
the off season to wherever urban meyer
ends up if he ends up back in the nfl
unclaimed on waivers yesterday chris
what do you believe is next for dwayne
haskins well
i mean it's i don't expect anything to
happen anytime
you know soon uh that that's for sure i
i think it's gonna be one of those
things where
yeah he's gonna have to you know take
some time off he's gonna be off a team
here for a little bit
you know his agent and his crew there
are going to have to start talking to
teams that
felt like maybe were interested during
the draft process
and they're going to have to try to find
teams that make sense for dwayne haskins
to kind of rebuild himself
listen nobody's going to bring him in to
be a starter we know that
really nobody is going to logically
bring him in to be a backup quarterback
right now
there's no way not just go like hey
we're going to sign you you're the
backup here that's not going to happen
you you can't as an nfl organization
trust him right now at this point
you'd have to see him and evaluate a
little bit and know he's on the
you know the right path before you're
going to anoint him as your backup
so he needs to find a team where really
he can go and be a third stringer
and have no pressure of playing or
performing and learn a little bit
learn to you know be a mature man
professional
all of those things and then he's gonna
have to rebuild from there
but to me it's something like that mike
that's where i said like yesterday the
pittsburgh steelers
that's a scenario look at you know you
know
another scenario i'm just throwing
scenarios out there right now to you
like okay the seattle seahawks right
they got
russell wilson they got geno smith
that's one that's two but then okay we
got dwayne haskins maybe he could be our
two
two years from now and maybe we by that
time
he could you know get himself righted to
where if russell wilson did get hurt
we could feel really good about man we
got dwayne haskins as a backup but we
can throw him in there to me it has to
be that sort of situation at this point
for haskins
and it has to be a situation he's
comfortable with well as it relates to
opportunities to develop eventual
opportunities
to play but he needs really good advice
on picking that next spot because he
needs maturity
he needs a team that believes in him he
needs an opportunity to grow he's 23
years old
it's too early to just say this guy's
done it's over and there are people who
are suggesting that it was some sort of
serious reach by washington to take him
with the 15th overall pick no it wasn't
somebody was taking him in the first
round somebody after washington was
going to take him
and if we got down into the 20s what was
going to happen is someone was gonna
trade back in
to round one and get him with that
five-year contract he was going in round
one
this wasn't some ridiculous what the
hell are they thinking type of a draft
pick
it just hasn't worked out it wasn't the
right spot for him it wasn't the right
player for the team
there's too much fluctuation and turmoil
and stuff happening in washington right
now
it just wasn't a good marriage and now
they move on
and they may have done him a huge favor
and this may be the wake-up call he
needs
chris carter's style early career
wake-up call
not that the problems are similar
between the two guys
but sometimes it's that indignity it's
that slap in the face
it's that hey you it's time to grow up
right that's what it takes to get a guy
to grow up and embrace what he needs to
do so
it's gonna be if he has multiple options
i mean it may be an easy call for him he
may only have one
option wherever urban meyer goes and if
it's not that the steelers i think as
you said yesterday make a ton of sense
but i don't see any reason to complicate
your life now
as a team to bring in a guy who doesn't
know your offense
who brings all that baggage right who
you'd have to get to know on the fly
it just doesn't make any sense for any
team to sign him for the playoff run
no you're exactly right nobody wants
that what okay yeah we bringing a guy in
playoff run and he's not gonna really
contribute to the team but he's going to
contribute to the
daily media session and the clamoring of
you know that story and all you know
team we know that teams don't want to
deal with that
dwayne haskins he's got talent he
i know he's a good kid i've heard too
many people say it
you know it's not a guy that's got
malice or meanness in him
yeah he's lost his way a little bit you
know and somebody needs to kind of show
him the right way here and and hopefully
he can find a team that does support him
the right way
has a little faith in him has a little
patience in him
and doesn't need him to be something
like to me that's where you take a shot
on him
you know again i'll throw another
scenario out there i don't know if this
exactly works right but like a team like
tampa that would be another team i would
think about
where i know they drafted the kid from
washington this year who's a big strong
arm kid but
you know hey brady one more year hey
let's have dwayne haskins in
let's see what maybe we can bring him
into something we like risk it no
biscuit throwing type of quarterbacks
who sit in the pocket
you know that's what he can do so uh but
but it ha
to me has to be something like that that
that would make sense for dwayne haskins
yeah look he's got to get another chance
he he's like i said he's 23
and young guys do dumb selfish stupid
things because i did plenty of them and
if i
had 10 million on top of that i mean i
did dumb stupid selfish things and i
didn't have any money
you give me money on top of it i'd have
been a thousand times worse so i can
understand
the situation but it's time to grow up
now this is it this is the moment this
is the reckoning
and this is the wake-up call for dwayne
haskins we'll see what happens with him
in 2021 because chris i think we both
agree we're not going to see him again
in uniform anywhere in 2020
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports